and his band present their latest album
at a record release party at berlin
spokespuna theater no jake's choice but
i like your voice
this time the group is playing at low
key with just a few musicians and
outfits that look almost civilized
this is the way it should be you go in
and think i hope this is good and then
it's better than you even thought it
would be
the feeling the atmosphere they created
it makes you crazy it's fabulous
i've seen a few bonaparte concerts but
this one was the most incredible
ultimate happening
bonaparte decided to try a new musical
direction with their fourth album
in new york as usual he composed and
recorded most of the songs on his own
i would say the fourth album is
different than the others it's got more
melodies and i sing again
there are some quieter songs too
but you can still feel the old bonaparte
style in the songwriting and the
attitude
it's not a complete change of direction
the first album too much came out in
2008 tobias became famous for wearing
circus jackets and animal heads
in 2006 tobias drove his car an old fiat
from switzerland to berlin and set up
shop
no this is not a gun in my pocket i'm
just glad to see you
airstone
it was my first and only car and i drove
it all over europe i zigzagged across
the alps spain everywhere
i slept on the back seat and took along
my guitar and laptop
you can hear that on the first album i
composed the songs more or less on the
road and somehow i landed in berlin via
spain
once in the german capital he found
musicians artists and dancers to
complete his act
the live shows made them famous
but after three albums and 550 gigs
bonaparte started hitting the buffers
in terms of energy we took it to the
limit we had nothing left to prove
we gave our
now it's more important to me to be
aesthetically adventurous and to do
something that means something to us
backstage with bonaparte at the berlin
concert their live shows used to involve
up to 20 people but now there's just two
musicians and two dancers the band
members have moved on many of them now
have kids tobias has two of his own
they're inside wearing pink tutus
but bonaparte haven't wandered far from
their original concept mine is fast on
the one hand it's important to have fun
to physically dance and show joy and
humor
and on the other you have to include
topics that are politically and socially
critical
besides that as long as bonaparte is
sensual or uses all senses then i'm
happy
happy
the fans in berlin are also happy
and this summer bonaparte will head out
on tour spreading their joy and humor at
festival stages across europe
watch
much